et puisque ça parle de moustache nos
aînés chroniqueurs vont nous faire de la
moustache et ce soir on va élire le
meilleur moustachu à mon avis ça va être
ça mettra sera mais on va avoir quand
même on va décaler on va commencer avec
jean me brassens c'est parti j'ai en
mémoire
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on s'est passé et c'est pas l'olympien
ici voilà jean michel maire c'est bien
alors alors si vous aimez mais à la
prestation
je pense non mais alors goûté on va
laisser juger les gens parce que
personnellement je trouve ça pas
terrible mais bon c'est juste sa
moustache où toute la presse abbas et
non c'est l'ensemble du moustachu est un
hommage au chanteur à moustache qui
était bien connu à cette époque avait
alors jean ferrat on n'est pas chanteur
à moustache
deuxième interrogation d'un célèbre
statue jean ferrat c'est une blague mais
bon jeu et si ça plaît à jean ferrat
tous abbas assez loin dans mes mains
alors c'est kelly khaled ces partis
cueillir à l'aide
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à al hicha
auj
gros m
j'ai passé
allez les effacer la balle est le même
c'est mauvais c'était mauvais si vous
n'avez mikkeli hashtag http moustachu
vie de kelly j'ai préféré que ni par
principe à jean mi j'ai pas vous non
plus d'accord alors ce rêve-là là on va
monter l'attenté d'un grand nous allons
recevoir daniel mercury d'année
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
tu
[Applaudissements]
et à
[Musique]
merci mais il n'ya pas que la voix qui l
est pas cette veste et l'a écoutée on
vous l'offre toute émission pas mal le
meilleur sosie de freddie mercury
c'est ça alors là c'est encore mieux
maintenant c'est bernard cabrel
[Applaudissements]
partie des chars tirent toujours des
belles phrases
[Applaudissements]
moi j'irai dormir chez vous mais moi
j'ai très peur là c'était non j'ai déjà
mon nom je dois dire que c'était un peu
habité oui peut-être l'invité
correctionnel s'est passé quelque chose
moi j'ai passé quelque chose ténors
alors là on a tout raté au 20 cents à
l'éasc et francky vincent c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
au québec
les places et là franchement à la la la
non là là franchement c'est pas possible
elle vous a plu non c'était pas terrain
dans franchement ici on dit ce qu'on
peut vous allez c'est pas terrible alors
maintenant on a on a on à christophe
alias max
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
facile
m
[Musique]
cc c'est s'est terminée par la
christophe mais même sa mère n'a pas
reconnu alain mais personne je
reconnaissais pas jeu verra pas jusque
là mais le prix grave
christophe à il a pris grave on lui met
légitimité aussi avec ce qu'estime voit
ça on n'en est plus là mais moi ce que
j'en suis inquiète on sait les cheveux
surtout mon la voix j'en parle pas alors
à alors ils disent à isart amie lisa
amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là c'était c'était bien qu'est ce que
vous avez dit la fille lourdes comme
s'extraire n'ai pas honte de dire c'est
une chose pareille aussi d'autres alors
on a maintenant on a maintenant je
géraldine magnum
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excusez moi c'était évident dans ces
différents pays a déjà commencé pas très
bien globalement d'être dans la peau de
tom selleck
ah oui j'avais envie d'avoir ces poils
d'avoir sa chemise d'avoir sa
musculature grand moment que pour vous
maintenant tiens on fait un grand saut
dans la dans la chanson française nous
avons delphine des musclés
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous êtes encore très belle merci
même avec la moustache et même les clips
aux cheveux allez une liste restera
toujours une mi-temps et enfin alors on
a gardé le meilleur ou le pire pour la
fin je ne sais pas c'est facile
morena montreynaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour enfants rois maudits
mon mac os
dans le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que c'est que cette tenue sans
rire non c'est par ici c'est eric déjà
eric ella et des amériques et la sai on
dirait il faut être shops et qu'est ce
que c'est que ça s'était tenue
épouvantable mustapha quand c'est cyril
vous faites un peu plus d'effort bon
vieux un fait vrai c'est ça c'est ça
allez allez vous asseoir si toute cette
mise en scène à gros budget pour pour
illustrer alors qui alors
vous pouvez désigner le chroniqueur que
vous souhaitez voir rester dans cette
tenue ridicule parce que vous savez quoi
à l'assumer sont disons à l'assumer
c'est absolument fait j'ai l'âge du
dollar us était dans l'esprit de freddie
mercury où il répété il faut alors
déguisement c'est aussi un pda
alors moi franchement mon préféré c'est
bernard
[Applaudissements]